let's focus on what's been a very
bruising week for the government with
brutal headlines from even usually loyal
newspapers
a weekend up at cop the verdict seems to
be mixed so far including on a coal
agreement that doesn't include the
world's biggest coal producers
environment food and rural affairs
secretary george eustis joined me now
live from the site in glasgow
good morning mr eustace
i want to start if i may with the words
of a former conservative prime minister
yesterday john major a man
no stranger to uh and being an
administration that was engulfed by
sleed sleaze said this about the owen
patterson affair
i think the way that the government
handled that was shameful
wrong and unworthy of this or indeed any
government it also had the effect of
trashing the reputation of parliament is
he right
no he's wrong and look i disagree with
john major on quite a few issues he's
not somebody whose cue i would normally
take and i think the point is here is
last week we tried to introduce an
appeal system in the uh the
parliamentary standards process i think
there's a consensus that there should be
some sort of appeal system such as that
the vote passed but there was obviously
unease because other political parties
said they weren't at this stage willing
to uh engage in that process but they
might be in the future and so uh it this
inevitably ended up being conflated with
the owen patterson issue so we we took
the decision uh not to proceed with that
but indeed to re-engage on an important
issue which is how do you have the right
of appeal and proper due process in
these instances
when you say
a decision not to proceed mr eustis i
think the words most commonly used about
that decision
are screeching u-turn you basically
changed your mind
well there was obviously as uh as jacob
rees-mogg pointed out as he um as he
withdrew this uh on the floor of the
house there was another in a degree of
controversy about this and the point is
you can only take these uh things
forward at the end of the day uh with
cross-party support you do need the
other parties to engage uh they uh took
the uh the view that they they were
going to sort of boycott this because
they didn't like the way it had been
done in this instance it's been very
important that these things are done in
a cross-party way so
to withdraw it was the right thing to do
well look um we're going in for
understatement here let's but let's turn
to
other conservative prime ministers um
mr cameron man who made an estimated 7
million pounds lobbying on behalf of
greensell firm collapsed owing hundreds
of millions of pounds and now the fir
serving prime minister a man furnished
with wallpaper costing 840 pounds a role
by a party donor now if we're talking
about trashing reputations both of the
conservative party
and of parliament um
those two things don't help do they
well i think it's important to to
recognize that in both instances both
the you know the allegations about david
cameron that was uh that was
investigated and the report came back
and said that he hadn't done anything um
you know anything wrong and the same's
true uh when it comes to the prime
minister uh lord guyt looked at this
issue when it was alleged months and
months ago now about wallpaper and
refurbishment and who bought the cost of
that and again he came back and
concluded there was no breach of the
ministerial code um the prime minister
you know paid uh for those upgrades um
uh you know over and above the the
annual allowance that prime ministers
get for uh working in their uh you know
in number 10. so again these have both
been looked at and um uh you know the
conclusion's been clear
if i may say so mr sir your french
friend would say that you're displaying
admirable software this morning i mean
real calm but on monday you failed to
persuade a hundred of your own mps to
toe the line on the paterson decision
and there's decision after decision
surely you must accept
government in trouble over this issue
not just of the specific decisions but
of character
of sleaze
well look i i know um you may put it to
me that way others opposition leaders
and so on
who and opposition politicians you'll
have on will no doubt uh say that but i
don't agree look i've been up here in
glasgow at cop later this week where
some really big decisions are being
taken big important commitments around
the world on a big
you know challenge like climate change
i think you know what we've seen it's a
sort of um you know westminster storm in
a teacup if i may say so uh yes we made
a mistake in bringing that forward in
the way that we did so we went through
it but um the overall principle that you
should have due process and a right of
appeal in these types of situations i
don't think anybody doubts
well you say we made a mistake now you
you were once director of communications
with the conservative party in fact i
think your press secretary to david
cameron um i would have loved to start
this interview talking about how we
saved the world this morning but surely
you would accept
given your past professional interest in
the way these things work out that it's
impossible now to think seriously about
those much larger issues with
uh what has happened this week a
paterson affair the echoes of uh prime
minister's own conduct and so on uh in
front of us
well it was ever thus i was press
secretary to two conservative party
leaders in opposition for four years
and
anyone in politics whether an opposition
or in government has that frustration
that the really big important things
that you're doing that you're making
progress on policy agendas at work um
are rarely deemed newsworthy um the news
agenda will always focus on uh you know
small um
often uh you know as i said storms in a
teacup and westminster rouse um it was
ever thus that's not new um but it
doesn't detract from the importance of
what we are managing to agree here in
glasgow uh a real positive vibe here
with uh countries around the world
making some really important uh
commitments particularly on nature
do you are you really trying to say that
um in those red wall seats that the
prime minister said have only lent you
their votes that they're basically
regarding this kind of thing as just a
small passing storm in a tea cup um if
only at the point from the point of view
of eyebrows being raised that
we're having to talk about all of this
again
at a moment when
we might be talking about finishing the
job on covid we might be talking about
rising prices we might be talking about
sorting out the problems with the eu
but here we are
talking again about the conduct of
members of parliament particularly
conservative members of parliament
does that not at all bother you do you
just think this is a a passing
cloud
well look uh obviously i i don't decide
the running order of your news agenda i
don't decide what newspapers should
write about and uh and rightly so you
don't want uh me deciding that but but
what i can do as a politician what the
government can do is focus on the issues
that really matter you know the truth is
we have come on a great success in
delivering the vaccine
come on come on you can't you can't i've
just got this
the media again
this is this is your these this is what
i'm not saying
this is your debate you chose you chose
to protect
mr patterson and then changed your mind
yes and i've explained precisely why we
brought it forward and that we thought
there was a good case for an appeals uh
system for due process i think actually
others would recognize that as well we
withdrew it because it got conflated
with an individual case i've explained
why we did that but trevor you put to me
specifically whether i'm uh you know
disappointed that this is top of the
news agenda rather than more important
things and yes um obviously i would like
to see more important things talked
about we've had a real successful
rollout of the vaccine we've got one of
the fastest growing economies fastest
growing in the g7 in fact as we come out
of this pandemic
yes we've got uh issues to deal with as
we come out of the pandemic but this is
a government that's really getting on
with those real challenges and here in
glasgow we're actually convening the
world to tackle a global challenge and
those are the issues that i've been
focused on this week
all right look i'm going to come to that
in just a second but let me take the
other part of john mage's attack which
is not specifically to do the
conservative party but politics itself
you know what's happened in the last
couple of months you've raised people's
taxes
petrol prices are up
mortgages the supermarkets shelves uh
are uh to some extent have been cleared
over the last couple of months
surely
people are right to say
all of that is going on and there they
are and this is all members of
parliament talking about themselves
again and this is not made up by the
media
this was parliament's parliamentary
business
it was set by
you and your colleagues and of course
the opposition
do you see that there's a problem here
well look parliament obviously deals
with all sorts of agendas across the
week recently i introduced a new bill
that's going to protect animal welfare
and ban the live export of animals which
is a manifesto commitment the
environment bill is going through
parliament at the moment that's going to
introduce due diligence in supply chains
to
you know make sure that forest risk
products like palm oil are sustainably
sustainably produced where organisms are
going to have a whole set of
environmental targets set under that
that's just on my uh brief and there'll
be other legislation and important
business of government going through
parliament at all times this is one
motion uh on an appeals process um
obviously yes of course it's attracted
more attention than some of those other
more substantive more important pieces
of legislation going through parliament
but it doesn't detract from the fact
that those are more important and those
are the issues that are taking up
government time
all right well let's turn to a big
substantive issue which is going on
where you are and that is uh cop 26.
um
gretel thunder tundberg has said yet
again it's blah blah blah photo
opportunities for leaders um you don't
have to go all the way with her
to
accept that there might be a problem you
signed a coal deal this week and that's
a big thing
but australia hasn't signed it the usa
hasn't signed it and china responsible
for about half the world's coal emission
hasn't signed it what is the point of
that
well some of those countries i think
china and the u.s in particular have
signed uh separate agreements i think
they were reached at g20 on ending
investments overseas on unabated coal so
that's a step forward always in these
multilateral agreements
different countries have got
different uh concerns
different circumstances you're never
going to be able to get everybody to
move the important thing is are you
overall moving the world forward and i
think to get over 100 countries
committed to phasing out coals a major
step forward
and i also think that if you look at the
fact that we've now got 90 yeah yeah but
we've got 90. that is the point overall
um well overall and you haven't got the
biggest contributors the head of the um
international energy agency faith barol
says that in the absence of those
countries australia china and so on the
target of keeping temperature at no more
than 1.5 percent above pre-industrial
levels the chances of doing that are
quote close to zero
close to zero
well we don't know obviously with the
measures that uh that are agreed once uh
cop concludes in a week from now
there'll be analysis about the impact of
that the big focus of this conference is
trying to keep at 1.5 degrees alive that
is during this century to try to hold
out the growth in global temperatures to
1.5 degrees we've now got around 90
percent of the world's economy committed
to net zero by the middle of the century
at this week also 120 countries pledged
to halt deforestation by 2030 that's a
major step forward the other thing we're
seeing at this cop and this is a big
change on previous ones
is donor countries mobilizing the
finance to actually deliver on the
policy pledges that are made that's been
difficult in previous years i've been
talking to the veterans of cop meetings
people in some cases who've attended the
last 20 of them and there's real
excitement and enthusiasm for the way
they were getting tangible progress here
in glasgow
well i i was where you are um a week ago
and i talked to the spokesperson for the
martial island and what she essentially
said to me
is that given that for example the
indians flew the indian prime minister
flew in and said yep we're going to get
to net zero but not till 2070. what she
was saying is that her country by the
time all this happens
is going to be a an x country it will be
extinct it will be drowned same will be
true for
some parts of bangladesh some will be
true for the maldives
you have to be honest and say this is
not going well is it
well look i i met uh tina the
representative of the marshall islands
at a panel discussion actually on friday
where we looked specifically at this the
small island states have actually got a
very big ocean area between them some of
the challenges that they face and the uk
government has made available funds and
finance to support some of the work
doing there sometimes using
nature and natural assets like corals to
help you know reduce
and deal with some of the flood risks
that they face but it's absolutely the
case that those small island states
particularly in places like the pacific
and the caribbean
are probably you know mostly risk
obviously from
rising sea levels for obvious reasons
george eustis thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you